give it up in my B
y'all Jason looking so flat his sequence
today I love it we have time y'all for
one last story that celebrates the
holiday spirit you're welcome Jason this
is what I'm
liking for me Christmas really isn't
Christmas without a decorated tree y'all
a man and M knows exactly what I mean so
when he realized there were people out
there who simply couldn't afford a tree
he set out to change that in the past 14
years he and his team have given away
more than 21,000 fresh cut trees to
families in need all over the country
from Christmas Tree Santa let's say
hello to Alex watching on news center M
what's up Alex hi Kelly happy
holidays I like your beautiful tree in
the background so this this is all this
started from your personal experience
right yeah that's exactly right you know
14 years ago I met a single mom who
couldn't afford a Christmas tree I had
had an old artificial tree in my
basement and I was able to give that to
her and she was so grateful and it
reminded me how much we take a tree for
granted I also thought about all these
other moms and dads who have the same
challenge they want but can't afford a
Christmas tree and I was inspired to do
something about it so I got together
with family and friends we started our
own nonprofit the Christmas tree Santa
and we had a very simple idea let's
invite all these families to an event
let's give away uh fresh cut Christmas
trees and all the trimmings and that
first year Killy we gave away 300
Christmas trees wow it grew year over
year over year and we added more sites
and more events now there are Santa
Volunteers in nine states and each year
we give away thousands and thousands of
Christmas trees all with lights
ornaments tree stands everything a
family needs to take it home and and
begin decorating and celebrating the
holidays that is so cool man I this has
to be this has to have such an impact on
the volunteers and the people working
this as well right yeah I I think you're
right I mean every year we meet so many
resilient and hardworking families many
are struggling and to be able to give
them a Christmas tree is a great gift
and many tell us it's the first tree
they've ever gotten I think for our
volunteers and for me it connects us
back to a deeper sense of meaning around
theol holidays and a sense of
communities I mean we're really just
parents helping other parents neighbors
helping neighbors and that's the real
gift that we're giving one another here
I think it's what makes Christmas Tree
Santa so special and it's what the
holidays are all about yeah Community
man thank you so much Alex I'm liking
your post right
now and that's not all man our season
long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to celebrate
people spreading holiday cheer in such
meaningful ways just like you sir so
they are going to give you $1,000 to
help out how's that
sound thank you so much Alex have such a
wonderful Christmas and thank you to all
our guests this hour Sydney Sweeney D
iJoy Randolph Laura zarion and Sarah
y'all have a great day and if it's not
try and
[Music]
changing
[Applause]
you guys y'all have a great night I'm
going
home